Untertitelung des ZDF, 2020
So.
Heute das
zwei Stunden... Ey, wir können
anfangen zu gucken, ja.
Wir können anfangen.
Ich muss mal kurz gucken,
wie warm es hier ist. Wartet mal kurz.
Ich kann die Klimaanlage wieder ausmachen.
Also, wohlgemerkt,
die Heizfunktion
von der Klimaanlage, also nicht
die Kühlfunktion von der Klimaanlage.
Ja, wünscht ihr auch.
MongoDB wurde gehackt.
Das habe ich, glaube ich, gestern oder so oder vorgestern.
Ich habe da irgendein Video zu geteasert bekommen von YouTube.
Habe ich nicht weiter mitgekriegt, was da genau gewesen ist bei MongoDB.
noch mal gucken mongo eb heck aufpassen dass man nicht gleich gebannt wird auf
switch irgendwelche wörter scan denken hier ist es voll hate speech ist das das
mongo blied heißt das oder war das nicht so dass nicht so dass das zeug ist
nicht irgendwo gelesen?
Gerade einen CCC-Beitrag
gelesen. Das Reichsbahn
von der Deutschen Bahn aufgelöst.
Gagweight.
Das können wir tatsächlich gucken.
Gleich mal.
Ich habe übrigens nichts. Ach, er ist das.
Okay, ja, dann mach gute Videos.
Ich habe nichts geplant für heute.
Ich bin extra jetzt nochmal angekommen.
Weil ich
wahrscheinlich heute Abend nicht on komme.
da dachte ich mir so ganz ohne gestreamte ist das ja auch nichts ich war mal update
massive update so viel messen ist es ganz auf dem korn update dabei update kann update kein
kölner update dabei was ist denn da los hier dies dies lecken aber voll über weihnachten
neuer bleeding edge körper das ist aber wahrscheinlich der neueste packet
tracer möglich ab der in das eigenes update ich jetzt auch nichts dauert
wieder 38 darauf dauert drei stunden
so genau wie ich das gar nicht wissen ist das das ja das ist die mongol db
geschichte oder
undergoing analysis analysis analysis
gut so viel ist ja das habe ich genau genau das habe ich mitgekriegt
updates jetzt ja gut packet tracer es gefällt es wirklich nicht gibt's chat
planen tool updates gibt es alles die haben auch nichts gearbeitet über
weihnachten und silvester was ich auch verstehen kann vollkommen zu recht
das heißt wir müssen auch gar nicht rebooten es geht doch einfach so umso
besser kann man theoretisch sogar noch 12
setke server aufgaben machen also wie gesagt haben nichts spezielles geplant
weil ich bin auch eingeloggt das ist ein inkognito tech ist wenn ich den hier zu
mache dann geht nichts mehr
Was meinst du mit Z-Lib?
Ja, das ist...
Problem bei MongoDB lag an irgendeiner
Compression Library,
wo irgendwas nicht richtig
escaped wurde oder sowas. Wie gesagt, ich hab mich
so nicht im Detail angeguckt.
Wird schon rewritten in SIG...
Wie? Moment, Moment.
Nicht blazingly fast die Krustentiere am Start.
Was ist denn da los?
X-Server rewritten.
Ist das...
A modern X-Server rewritten from scratch.
Tja, das wäre im Prinzip auch ganz gut.
Aber vielleicht sollte man das auf einer ordentlichen Plattform machen, wo es auch gefunden wird.
Oder gibt's das nicht auf GitHub, oder?
Ich hab immer den Eindruck, alle Projekte, die nicht auf GitHub sind,
sind irgendwie fast immer zum Scheitern verurteilt.
Also, Projekte, die schon groß sind und dann von GitHub weg sind, woanders hin.
Okay.
Es ist aber auch richtig und richtig und wichtig, wie man so schon sagt heutzutage.
Oh, wir haben 6-7 Zuschauer.
Es ist aber auch richtig, ganz ehrlich
Ich hab letztens wieder einen richtig langen
Wayland-Rant auf Reddit gelesen
Weiß nicht, ob ich den jetzt finde
Ist es das?
Ja, das ist es
Richtig, richtig schön langen
Wayland-Rant hab ich wieder gelesen
Letztens hier auf Reddit, das da
Und er hat schon rechts
der hat schon recht ich war in wales wie alt mittlerweile 15 jahre oder irgendwie steht das
irgendwie das ist uralt wayland schon also ja 15 jahre oder keine ahnung und da tun es teilweise
basic sachen immer noch nicht und das problem ist halt x ist halt komplett support macht kein
mensch mehr irgendwas dran und außer der eine typ der x gefolgt hat der sich
irgendwie gezofft hat mit den entwicklern und dann nichts gefolgt hat
macht kein mensch was dran und weiland kackt ab ich war ein körper ich könnte
legit mein linux nicht verwenden mit wayland würde nicht funktionieren
es würde einfach nicht funktionieren weil es in der fremdlich richtig
funktioniert mag sein dass es irgendeinen wayland kompositor gibt der
dann doch funktioniert wie auch immer zumindest das was ich ausprobiert habe
mit hyperland und sway hat nicht richtig funktioniert und das ist überhaupt erst
mal startet und so aussieht als würde es laufen ist auch erst ein jahr oder so
oder zwei Jahre maximal her.
Davor ging es gar nicht. Davor war das Problem,
wenn du Fenster resized hast, hat
er nicht die Fenster resized, sondern
das Fenster gleich gelassen und einfach nur
größer skaliert.
Ganz, ganz weirdchampig.
Also,
ich
weiß nicht.
Ja, und ich wüsste auch gar nicht, wie ich es
gescheit auf der Arbeit verwenden sollte,
ohne
Oldschool-X-Gedöns,
weil ich benutze da ganz viel X-Forwarding.
Also,
weiß nicht, ob das
gescheit noch funktioniert, wenn dann wirklich
überall alles nur noch Wayland supportet.
Also,
den Thread habe ich gelesen
und den lesen wir jetzt nicht,
der ist ganz schön lang, aber der hat schon
durchaus ein paar
gute Punkte drin gehabt.
Zum Beispiel, dass die Wayland-Leute
alles irgendwie auf Security schieben,
wo man sich halt fragt, so, but why?
Und was ich auch ganz gut finde, ist das hier.
Solche Sachen.
Im Prinzip ist das hier alles relativ valid Punkte.
Gut, er entwickelt irgendwelche OpenGL-Geschichten und kann die nicht richtig debuggen unter Wayland.
Okay, verstehe ich, habe ich jetzt selbst noch nicht gemacht.
Dass es keinen X-Kill gibt, das war mir gar nicht bewusst.
Du kannst unter Wayland keine Anwendung einfach killen.
dass das war das war mir in der tat gar nicht bewusst dass das nicht geht das
ist keine gescheiten desktop automatisierung gibt das wusste ich und
dass es probleme gibt mit hotkeys das wusste ich auch dass es probleme gibt
mit screen rot screen recording und screenshot tools das wusste ich auch
also das sind so komplette super basic geschichten wo man sich eigentlich gar
nicht darüber gedanken macht geht das das nimmt man einfach für das geht das
nimmt man einfach so so hin das muss sein aber nicht so ja obs hat genau obs
hat auch richtig probleme unter und gehabt oder hat immer noch dann ist auch
das problem bei screenshot tools dass die teilweise sich nicht richtig
positionieren können und nicht auf inhalte von anderen fenstern zugreifen
müssen und das ganze können und das ganz ganz gut und gut kann man kann ich jetzt ehrlich gesagt
nichts zu sagen ich habe noch nie einen kalibrierten monitor unter linux verwendet aber wenn er das
sagt glaube ich ihm das war und und was ich auch was mich auch immer immer richtig träger hat bei
leuten die auf so mario danke für den sub die auf sowas dann antworten teilweise mit ja wie das muss
so sein warum will man denn sowas hier machen warum will man denn sowas machen
stellen so was sie ju legit don't need global hotkeys oder sowas warum nicht
außerdem ist immer noch entscheidung vom user letztendlich wasser brauchen was
nicht
Naja.
Katzi.
Also ich kann dir erzählen, dass beispielsweise bis vor einem Jahr hat Screen Refresh nicht funktioniert in VMware mit Wayland.
Also der Screen hat nicht refreshed, das war nicht benutzbar, weil es immer Standbild war.
Der Screen hat einfach nicht refreshed.
Das war komplett nicht benutzbar.
Ganz vergessen.
Ja, ist übrigens immer noch nicht
Benutzbar mit Hyperland
Zum Beispiel in der VM
Da kannst du
90% der Programme nicht
Starten
Also es ist voll für den Arsch
Jetzt kann man sich natürlich überlegen
Auf wen man es schiebt
Schiebt man es auf Wayland
Die Leute die sich das ausdenken
Schiebt man es auf die die es implementieren mit Hyperland
Ja doch
Letztendlich ist es mir doch scheißegal wo das Problem herkommt
liegt es an vmware liegt es an den leuten die weiland sachen design sind es die leute die
hyperland implementieren oder sowas in der richtung das ist mir vollkommen wurscht bei
x ging das einfach ja ja ihr habt mich als trinken erinnert okay ich trinke
es ist übrigens nicht ein hyperland problem und das way ist das gleiche problem
Soll ich jetzt erstmal alle 50
Window Manager da ausprobieren
Bis ich einen finde, wo
Most basic Sachen funktionieren
Und dann wäre für andere Sachen nicht
Oder wie
Ey, das kann es nicht sein
Und wahrscheinlich ist das Problem wieder mal
An allen möglichen Stellen
Das ist bestimmt eine Kombination
Aber so Diskussionen
Triggern mich echt einfach hardcore
Dieses mit, ja, aber das ist doch kein
Problem davon, ja, aber das ist doch kein
problem davon bis hier wie lange wir unter linux rum gemacht haben bis gpu decoding von videos
funktioniert bis sie belang das hat ewig gedauert bis bis wie bis gpu decoding von videos im browser
unter linux funktioniert das hat ewig gedauert hat jahre gedauert also wenn das unter windows
ging da ging es also in der windows und mac ging es wahrscheinlich ungefähr zeitgleich wird sogar
sagen das ist geschichte wahrscheinlich unter windows zuerst funktioniert hat weiß es nicht
aber sagen wir mal wenn es seit 2010 unter windows funktioniert hat hat seit 2020 angefangen mit hex
unter linux zu funktionieren gpu browser video decoding war ein hin und her unter linux woran
liegt es legt es an den browser herrscht liegt es an den mesa treibern entwickler liegt es an den
gpu hersteller liegt es an den gpu treibern der stelle geht es an x liegt es an wayland liegt es
was auch immer liegt es am Linux-Körner vielleicht sogar, haben sich alle wahnsinnig auf, System D, haben sich alle wahnsinnig aufgeregt und letztendlich war es überall ein bisschen, aber es war halt kompletter Abfuck, das kannst du keinem erklären.
Das ist halt manchmal echt ein bisschen nervig unter Linux.
Also, zumindest eins kann man, denke ich, sagen.
Gibt es irgendjemand, der diese Windows-Seitenleiste da...
Oh, was macht denn das da?
Was habe ich jetzt gemacht?
Ordentlich verwendet, wirklich benutzt.
Zumindest können wir eins sagen, 2026 sind wir wahrscheinlich noch nie so nah dran, wie bisher gewesen, am Jahr des Linux-Desktops.
Ich glaube nicht wirklich, dass 2026 das Jahr des Linux-Desktops wird.
Ich glaube auch übrigens nicht, dass es jemals so etwas wie das Jahr des Linux-Desktops geben wird.
Ich glaube nicht, dass sich das nicht durchsetzt.
Aber das wird nicht so sein, Jahr X verwendet kaum einer was, nächstes Jahr, BÄM, jeder verwendet Linux.
Das wird es nicht sein, das wird so eine Schritt-für-Schritt-Adoption sein.
Aber zumindest sind wir dann 2026 so nah dran wie noch nie vorher.
Das klicke ich jetzt nicht an.
Wer weiß, wo ich da rauskomme?
Achso, Moment, Moment, okay, ich hab's mir angeguckt
Das kann man...
Windows 10 stirbt
Warum...
Warum ist das...
Warum ist das laminiert?
Hängt das irgendwo rum?
Wobei es ist nicht einlaminiert, es steckt nur in so einer Klarsichtfolie.
Windows 10 stirbt nach dem 14.
Oktober 2020.
Keine Updates.
Angebot klappt nicht.
Wenn sie bereits sind, heißt Linux.
das klappt tatsächlich erstaunlich gut ich habe meinen vater ja schon vor über
einem jahr oder so oder zwei jahre zwei jahre sind das schon her locker auf so
einem mini pc linux mint installiert ich habe auch so updates eingerichtet das übrigens ein
Wo kriegt man das her? Sieht so Roblox-mäßig aus. Linux Mint auf so einen Mini-PC drauf gemacht.
So ein Minis, Minis, kleiner Minis Forum PC. So ein Teil in der Richtung hier, so was in der
Richtung hat er. Und der benutzt das ohne wirklich zu wissen, dass das Linux ist. Aber der macht mit
seinem Rechner ja auch nichts.
Der klickt im Browser ein bisschen
rum und schreibt
mit seinen angeblichen Freundinnen.
Also ich sage jetzt angeblich, weil das Love-Scamming ist.
Aber er lässt sich nicht
davon abbringen.
Was ich ja witzig finde, früher hat er
die Leute mit sowas gescampt, heute wird er gescampt.
Das weiß ich nicht. Könnte ich mir durchaus vorstellen,
dass die
AI generated sind.
Und eine von denen hat ihm jetzt sogar erzählt, er wäre Vater geworden.
Und wahrscheinlich hat er ihr ein AI-generiertes Bild geschickt vom Kind, was so aussieht wie er.
Ich kann nichts dagegen machen, Leute.
Das klingt jetzt vielleicht lustig oder auch schockierend, je nachdem, wie ihr das seht.
Aber ich kann nichts dagegen machen.
Ich habe ihm das schon hundertmal gesagt.
Und seine Antwort darauf ist immer, ich habe ihm auch schon gesagt, die verarschen dich.
Und die erzählen dir sonst was.
sie erzählen dir was sie hören will, sagt, mich verarscht keiner.
Wenn mich einer verarschen will, merke ich das in den ersten zwei Sekunden, hat er gesagt.
Letztens dazu.
In den ersten zwei Sekunden merkt er das.
Er hat so viele Leute verarscht, hat er erzählt,
wenn er merkt, dass in den ersten zwei Sekunden, wenn er verarscht wird.
Ich kann ihm das nicht ausreden.
Das lässt sich gerne weiter love scammen.
Darüber weist er da auch teilweise Geld hin und sowas.
Tja.
Fragt man nach 100k Kredit.
Wenn hier einer wen nach dem Kredit fragt, ist mein Vater das mich.
Mein Vater hat mich schon öfters angepumpt, als ich meinen Vater.
Ich habe meinen Vater noch nie angepumpt.
Und der mich bestimmt schon 5 mal oder so.
Und mit den abenteuerlichsten Geschichten hat er mir.
Also meine Lieblingsgeschichte, ich glaube die habe ich ja schon mal erzählt.
Also die Lieblingsgeschichte ist ja immer noch, wo er mal Geld haben wollte.
Da war er zufälligerweise dort, wo die Love Scammer sind.
Da war er in der Karibik irgendwo, Dominikanische Republik.
Da, wo seine Love-Scammer-Mädels wohnen, da hat er sich dann auch vor Ort scammen lassen.
Ich will es gar nicht wissen, was da gelaufen ist.
Keine Ahnung, ich will es gar nicht wissen.
Zumindest hat er mir eine E-Mail geschickt.
Das müsst ihr euch mal vorstellen, ja.
Ihr macht eine E-Mail auf von eurem Vater und da steht sinngemäß drin,
Er wurde entführt und er wird hier festgehalten und braucht 500 Euro Lösegeld.
So sinngemäß stand das da drin.
Und da habe ich erstmal gedacht, was? Moment, Moment, das ergibt doch keinen Sinn.
Das ergibt doch keinen Sinn.
Du bist entführt, kannst aber E-Mails schreiben und dann irgendwie auch so ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz weird und sowas.
ne, ganz wild, aber ich hab mir gedacht, okay
der wird irgendwelche
größeren Probleme haben und ich will
den da jetzt nicht sitzen lassen
und da hab ich ihm 500 Euro überwiesen
und wisst ihr was gewesen ist, ich hab's
im Nachhinein rausgekriegt
ja, wünschen wir dir auch
ähm, wisst ihr was gewesen ist, ich hab das im Nachhinein
rausgekriegt
der war dort im Urlaub, oder halt
da bei seinen Love Scam Mädels
und, ähm
war im Krankenhaus
weil er
irgendwie sich wieder eingebildet hat,
was zu haben oder so.
Ähm, und
der war im Krankenhaus, hat sich behandeln
lassen und wollte abhauen, ohne
zu bezahlen.
Und da haben die gesagt, nee, nee,
Herr Papa von Max,
Sie bleiben jetzt mal schön hier,
wir lassen Sie nicht weg,
bevor Sie nicht bezahlt haben.
Das war die Wahrheit
dahinter.
Von wegen, er wurde entführt.
Die haben gesagt, sie dürfen nicht weg, bevor sie nicht die Kohle bezahlen haben, weil er sich verpissen wollte.
So Zeug hat er schon öfters getrieben.
Das ist grausam teilweise.
Und der hat sich schon deutlich mehr gepumpt, wie gesagt, von mir als ich von ihm.
Ich habe mir noch nie was von dem geliehen.
Würde ich auch nicht machen.
bekommst du das geld immerhin quatsch ich habe noch nie wieder eine sache von
dem je zurückbekommen
am geilsten war ja auch noch da hat ja auch damals wo ich klein war wo ich
klein war als der hier weg war ja und meine mutter hat sitzen lassen mit mir
da ist er dann wirklich irgendwann mal angekommen und hat sich von der geld geliehen alleinerziehende
mutter mit kind die kein geld hat das hat er bis heute noch nicht wieder bezahlen und nicht
zurück bezahlt machte auch nicht mehr und wenn man ihn darauf anspricht sagt er so was wie ach
das ist doch verjährt ja mag zwar rechtlich gesehen so sein moralisch gesehen ist das
sicherlich nicht verirrt.
Den Keil kannst du voll vergessen
in der Richtung, ja. Komplett.
So, jetzt sind wir ein bisschen sidetracked worden.
Wie gesagt, ich hab heute gar nichts Spezielles
vor oder so.
Einfach ein bisschen
schwätzen. Wir können gleich
das Video zum MongoDB
Hack gucken.
Und ein bisschen von den C++-Videos
oder was auch immer.
Von was zahlt er gerade seine Rechnung?
Er hat doch bestimmt nicht seine Steuernrente bezahlt.
Der hat Glück gehabt.
Mein Vater hat richtig Glück gehabt, was das angeht mit Rente.
Selbst würde der gar keine Rente bekommen, großartig.
Der hat so gut wie nichts einbezahlt in die Rentenversicherung.
Mein Vater kriegt aber Witwenrente, weil der war verheiratet das dritte Mal.
und
also
nochmal, nach meiner Mutter,
war da nochmal verheiratet
und die war Beamtin.
Und die ist gestorben,
bevor sie sich hat scheiden lassen können.
Die wollte sich nämlich scheiden lassen.
Da hat er gerade nochmal
Glück gehabt.
Indirekt
habe ich auch Glück gehabt.
Also was heißt Glück? Glück ist ein Scheißwort
dafür. Das muss ich jetzt mal zurückziehen.
Weil ich
finde das sehr bedauerlich.
Also
die hätte
mein Vater überleben sollen.
Aber
insofern
habe ich Glück gehabt,
weil wenn der
nicht seine Witwenrente kriegen würde,
dann
würde er
laufend hier auf der Matte stehen und würde sich
Geld leihen wollen.
Neues Mega-Lag-Video zu Han...
Was für ein Ding?
Weiß ich nicht.
Ja, das war so.
Die wollte sich scheiden lassen.
Also sie war ja schon vorher krank.
Wollte sich aber noch scheiden lassen,
aber es hat nicht mehr geklappt.
Das war nicht in Hanau.
Aber insofern, für mich ist es, zumindest hat es einen positiven Aspekt, dass er mir nicht laufend auf der Tasche liegt mit Kohle, weil er Witwenrente kriegt.
Witwer-Rente.
Ansonsten tut mir das echt leid, dass sie nicht mehr lebt.
Das ist echt die Letzte, die sowas verdient hat.
Naja, egal. Das sind keine unerfreulichen Sachen hier.
Hast du sie gekannt? Ja, ich fand, ich hab mich mit der ganz gut verstanden sogar.
Ich hab mich mit der, glaube ich, besser verstanden als mit meinem Vater.
Gibt ja die Browser-Extension namens Honey.
Da wurde aufgenommen, dass sie im großen Stil Provisionen von Creators...
Und was für eine Browser-Extension ist das?
Das kenne ich nicht.
Ich lebe, glaube ich, hinter dem Mond, aber okay.
Was genau...
was soll das sein aber immerhin 46 sterne automated coupons und rewards
nee habe ich nicht mitgekriegt ich dachte ich lebe vielleicht bis in
hinterm Mond, aber das habe ich nicht mitgekriegt.
Bei AliExpress kriegt man da...
Aha, okay. Auch nicht schlecht.
Nee, ich
habe da echt keine Ahnung von.
Ich habe nichts, nichts davon,
nichts davon mitgekriegt.
Zwei Millionen User weniger
als letztens, die haben...
Wollen wir mal gucken.
Hami-Influencer-Betrug
auf Decken.
Moment. Das ist in
englisches Video. Warum ist der Titel auch... Achso, weil YouTube
wieder Übersetzungsstells macht.
Oh, nochmal gucken.
21 Minuten, oder?
Und hat sie nicht, sondern die vorgeschlagen,
die gesponsert wurden, oder wie?
Oder was war da der...
Was war der Scam?
Letztendlich kann man sich
aber immer eine Sache überlegen.
Sobald was kostenlos
ist, ja,
ist man selbst das Produkt.
Egal bei was,
muss man sich immer überlegen, okay, was haben die denn
davon, wenn sie sich das kostenlos anbieten?
Wo wir gerade beim Thema kostenlos sind.
Ich zeige euch mal was erfreuliches,
kostenloses. Gehen wir mal in irgendein
Projekt.
Ich bin noch seit
den Weihnachtsferien
so ein bisschen am AI-Zeug ausprobieren.
Und ich bin jetzt ja,
ich habe mich jetzt ja auf OpenCode eingeschossen.
OpenCode ist quasi sowas wie CloudCode,
nur open mit allen möglichen Models,
die man verwenden kann.
Und das ist richtig nice,
denn, denn, das gibt es sonst nirgends wo.
Ich habe ja keine Subscription.
Ich habe weder eine Cloud-Subscription
noch eine Google-AI-Dings,
wie heißt das plattform studio war so immer subscription und ich habe auch
keine copilot subskription sonst was ich mache das alles immer free und das ist
echt nice weil in open code ist glm 4.7 kostenlos drin minimax m 2.1 kostenlos
mit drin und gpt 5 nano kostenlos mit drin kann man benutzen kann man es jetzt
auch wo man nämlich gerade beim thema kosten kann man sich jetzt auch
überlegen ist man da nicht vielleicht selbst das produkt wenn man es benutzt
Das ist aber wirklich richtig, richtig nice.
Das sind alle drei...
Okay, gut, GPT-5 Nano.
GPT-5 Nano benutze ich nur, um schnelle Antworten zu bekommen.
Das ist nicht so geil.
Zum Beispiel könnt ihr fragen, was ist das beste Twitch-Emote?
So, irgendwie sowas.
Dann ist GPT-5 Nano halt sehr zackig.
Ja.
Aber ich benutze das teilweise.
also ich benutze gerne glm glm 4.7 und in letzter zeit probiere ich mal ein bisschen mini mini max
m 2.1 aus da kann man zum beispiel sachen so sachen fragen so was ich keine ahnung
was das projekt baut und dadurch dass das lokale programmes kann er auch das jetzt ein bisschen
langsamer. Kann der auch nachgucken
bei mir im Verzeichnis
und Dateien lesen
und sowas.
Und dann kann er mir sagen, okay,
in diesem Projekt geht es um folgendes.
Gucken, wie gut das ist.
Dann habe ich noch zwei MCP-Server
angeschlossen, angebunden.
MCP ist
...
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wofür MCP steht.
Vielleicht wisst ihr das.
Guck jetzt mal die Zusammenfassung von dem Projekt, was wir hier kriegen.
Es ist eine Rust-Web-Application
mit Axiom, Tokio, Proc, FS, Clap.
Run of Port sowieso,
sowieso. Kostet halt alles nix.
Model Context Protokoll. Genau, du hast recht.
Du hast recht. Ja. Ja.
Und
Da ist meine Set Server To Do drin.
Hat keinen Sinn.
Und zumindest, zumindest
ist das alles kostenlos. Was mega nice
ist.
Und das ist auch
echt hilfreich.
also ich hab da jetzt die letzten tage schon viel viel rumprobiert und das ist
echt das beste setup was ich gefunden habe hier ich mag ich mag terminal
den moment also ich mag ich mag terminal programme ja das ist ein super super
user terminal user interface und dadurch dass du drei gute models verwenden kannst
kostenlos. Ist das, finde ich,
so echt der Knaller.
Open Code. Ich habe eine relativ
umfangreiche...
Wieso bindest du nicht
schnell einfach ein lokales Model an?
Du meinst QuenCoder3?
Naja.
Weil der Tool-Support von
QuenCoder3 Schrott ist.
Lokale Models,
ganz ehrlich,
die, die bei mir in die Grafikkarte
passen,
habe ich keins gefunden,
was mich wirklich groß überzeugt
hat. Läuft das alles
lokal oder ist das in der Cloud?
Wie gesagt, ich habe hier
LM Studio am Start für lokale Models.
Ich habe noch kein gutes lokales
Model gefunden, was bei mir in der Grafikkarte
schnell läuft, also was in den Grafikkarten
speichert, also maximal 24 Gig
und
mir beim Programmieren gefällt.
Was ich mal lokal laufen hatte, was ganz okay war zum ausprobieren war ChatGPT OSS.
Aber da kann ich auch hier kostenlos GPT-5 Nano verwenden oder so.
Also lokale Models ist leider nicht so das.
Deswegen es geht mir nicht darum, dass es Open Source Models sind, sondern wirklich,
man die gehostet kostenlos benutzen kann oder dass man abo braucht und was was ich was ich
hier noch als mcp server drin habe ich kann gleich was dazu sagen was hier noch als mcp
server drin sind zwei sachen die finde ich auch sehr praktisch es gibt einmal kontext
servent kontext der finn ist quasi eine api für so programme wie open code wo man zu großen
projekten auf github aktuelle infos bekommt weil es ist ja immer so die models werden zu zeitpunkt
x trainiert und wenn danach neue funktionen dazu kommen oder vielleicht das nicht in den
trainings daten drin war was auch immer dann haben die keine ahnung davon und spucken der code aus
wie vor zwei jahren vielleicht geschrieben hätte das aber heute nicht mehr und mit kontext erfen
hat Open Code, oder besser gesagt hier
GLM 4.7 hat Zugriff
auf aktuelle Projekte und
Source Code Docs und Hilfe
Seiten und sowas. Das ist sehr praktisch. Und dann habe ich noch angebunden,
aber nur die Free Version. Nur noch die Free Version habe ich noch
Tavili angebunden. Das ist eine Suchmaschine. Da kann man
direkt aus seiner aus das model kann quasi direkt internet suchen
durchführen was sonst immer ein bisschen schwierig ist weil man sonst in
irgendwelchen captchas und quotas und so landet aber da habe ich auch nur das
fried hier das heißt benutze ich auch nur manchmal aber ich finde das ist
richtig gutes setup
wie gesagt alles alles in der cloud so also jetzt mal kurz gucken was hältst du von sicherheits
architekt und was hältst du von der sicherheitsarchitektur für eine plattform ach ja
wo man gerade beim thema weiß muss schon mal sagen weil er sagt im vibe coder ich benutze
das immer also ich hab da ich weiß nicht ob es dafür auch einen einen namen gibt ich benutze
es eher so als weib inspiration inspiration heißt inspiration was heißt es auf englisch
inspiration weib inspiration benutze ich das ich lasse also ich habe noch nicht mal erlaubt
dass meine agents lokale files editieren dürfen also ist nichts mit weib coden aber ich fragte
gerne so nach dem motto kann man das hier noch irgendwie besser moderner machen in sprache xy
oder so sieht das in go aus wie würde man das in rust machen oder warum ist das und das nicht in
der ausgabe drin habe ich irgendwas übersehen und so was das ist richtig nice und ich muss sagen
sagen ohne scheiß gerade gerade glm 4.7 ist als finde ich finde ich finde ich
richtig gut wir können wir können das ja mal irgendwas fragen vielleicht
irgendwas irgendwas sinnloses irgendwas sinnloses mal fragen keine ahnung so
Chancen.
Ist da irgendwas drin, was man uns fragen könnte?
Wir fragen einfach mal, könnte man den Code noch schöner machen?
Okay.
Könnte man den Code in
Add, kann man nämlich auch
Dateien hinzufügen. Guck hier mit.
noch schöner
und derner und besser
machen. Mal gucken, was das sagt.
Also, GLM 4.7
ist jetzt nicht das schnellste Model, wie man
sieht. Das thinkt
relativ viel.
VibeThinker.
Guck mal, schon fertig. Okay.
Ja, der Code lässt sich definitiv verbessern.
Hier sind die Hauptprobleme.
Okay, unbenutzte Importe.
Ja, who cares?
Tote Variablen.
Ja, okay, aber es ist nicht schlecht, dass das...
Receiver laggt, wird nicht explizit behandelt.
Das ist tatsächlich ein Problem.
Imports sind unsortiert, Fehler haben keinen Kontext.
Ach was, hardcoded Adresse.
Ach was, fehlender Graceful Shutdown.
Ja, ist wohl wahr.
Und jetzt sagt er mir, wie man es besser machen könnte.
Das finde ich in der Tat sehr praktisch.
Ich würde nie auf die Idee kommen, das jetzt eins zu eins zu nehmen und irgendwie da rein zu pasten.
Denn in Linta könnt ihr das erkennen, aber in Linta könnt ihr dir nicht sagen, wie man es verbessern könnte.
Es könnte höchstens ein generelles Beispiel geben.
Normalerweise deutet das darauf hin, dass bla bla bla.
und das das finde ich so zur inspiration immer ganz ganz weil das hier kann dir kein linter
sagen linter kann dir sagen es werden nicht alle cases gehandelt so nach dem motto ja aber linter
wird könnt ihr nicht sagen hier implementiere das doch vielleicht mal so und so gut man muss
halt auch sagen das ist jetzt sehr wichtig ist da wäre ich jetzt auch so noch drauf gekommen
soll ich speichern ein oder nicht speichern aber jetzt gucken wir noch mal hier was hältst
du von der sicherheitsarchitektur für eine plattform bimma ist ein baulehrer 1 tls
ach so jetzt verstehe ich das verschiedene tls ja gut
ai plattform inwiefern
jetzt chat web chat oder
wie jetzt was genau also dass die verbindung wird dass das sollte ja basic sein dass die
sachen verschlüsselt sind zwischen klein und server layer 2 security ich habe
Da muss ich passen.
Ich habe überhaupt keinen Plan,
was das meiste davon ist.
Das einzige, was ich schon mal gehört habe,
ist HSTS.
Rest habe ich keine Ahnung, was das ist.
Korb?
Cross kenne ich noch.
Das, das, das, das, okay,
das sagt mir auch, das ist Cross.
Side Request Forgery Protection.
Ja, das ist sinnig.
Keine Ahnung von.
Session Management.
Redis IP.
Kein Schimmer, wie du das am besten machst.
Na gut, Input Validation muss immer sein.
Alles...
Ich meine...
Zumindest auf Serverseite.
audit locking je nachdem was du in deutschland anbieten willst du nicht weiß ich was da
vorgeschrieben ist ist das erstellt dass so viel buzzword auf einmal da kann ich das ist
way too dank.
Ich habe auch gedacht,
das ist der Allgenerated-Symbol.
Du möchtest AI-Chat-Sessions anbieten.
Backend Rust.
Performance Memories.
Das ist doch AI-generated.
Ich wusste, dass das AI-generated ist.
Ich habe mittlerweile schon
ein Gespür dafür.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist so ein Passwort.
Mix.
wir können ja war okay okay wisst ihr was chat
generated versus generated
und dann fragen wir noch mal
wir fragen wir fragen auch noch mal hier den k modus von chrome ja aber jetzt aber
ein generator was sei ein generate kürzest dazu sagt die schön für den
zapf ach ja und freund habe ich irgend einen zapf übersehen kann das sein moment moment
Moment mal, ich muss gucken.
Okay, AI kann mit 30 Milliarden Seiten antworten.
Auf AI-generated Sachen.
Mr. Brauland, ich finde es ab.
Mario, POC-Subscription.
Ne, also so Leute, AF-Programmer, so schlimm ist auch bei uns auf der Arbeit nicht.
Guck mal, die AI ist darauf voll angesprungen.
Die hat erstmal einen halben Roman rausgehauen
zu deiner Geschichte.
Das ist eine sehr solide
und umfassende Sicherheitsarchitektur.
Lass mich jeden Layer analysieren
und dir konstruktives...
Okay, aha, sehr gut.
Security Headers, ausgezeichnet.
Layer 3, gute Wahl.
Stark.
Kritisch für AI.
Warum ist Audit Locking besonders kritisch für Compliance und Forensik unverzichtbar?
What?
Das sind eigentlich schon wieder Zap.
Potenzielle Verbesserung. Aha.
By the way, was ist Fall Layer Mass Defense?
Und was zum Teufel ist... Alter, das ist ja...
Mehr Buzzwords wie bei irgendeinem Management-Ding.
Injection Sanitization... Ich kann das ja nicht einmal aussprechen.
Was soll das bitte schon sein?
Injection Sanitization...
Was soll das?
Die meinen quasi, du sollst überprüfen, was die User als Input schicken und das quasi nochmal, wie soll man sagen, es capen ist das falsche Wort, mal checken, ob das Sinn ergibt.
layer 9 rate limiting und den os protection das ist immer hier die lm 4.7 kann was hast du benutzt
opus du hast du irgendwas geschrieben kann opus ja ganz auf was man kann aber was beibringen
Das ist doch einfach
Also das ist natürlich
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie wirkt das wie eine wilde Aneinanderreihung
Von Dingern
So
Guck mal, du kriegst
Guck mal, jeder hat sogar noch eine Tabelle unten drunter
Naja, okay
Jetzt nochmal just for fun fragen wir jetzt nochmal was
Wahrscheinlich irgendeine Gemini 3
Variante davon denkt
Hochgradig professionell, ja da kann nichts mehr schief gehen. Dann wünsche ich dir viel Erfolg, Keck Business.
Und
Wenn du mir auch mal hunderttausende für Consulting bezahlen willst, dann nur zu.
Stops.
Hast du Kollegen auf der Arbeit oder Freunde,
die ohne AI gar nichts machen?
Freunde habe ich ja prinzipiell nicht.
Kennt mich ja.
Und es bei jeder Gelegenheit nutzen müssen,
um eine dreizeilige Mail zu schreiben.
Nee, haben wir nicht.
Also wir haben welche, die stehen sehr auf AI-Zeug.
Zum Beispiel,
unser Azubi
macht ja ein Abschlussprojekt
und die Software,
die er da benutzt, die ist
Vibe-Coded.
Aber nicht von ihm, wohlgemerkt.
Nicht von ihm Vibe-Coded.
Die hat er schon Vibe-Coded
vorgesetzt bekommen.
Ja, generell ist mir das aufgefallen.
Ich habe ja auf der Arbeit eine
Firmen...
Wie heißt das da? Lizenz oder so
für Gemini.
Kann man dann verwenden auch in Visual Studio Code
und sowas.
Und das sagt gefühlt bei jeder
Frage so nach dem Motto
Ah, ein sehr guter Punkt.
Sehr gute Lösung.
Der schleimt dich erstmal
zwei, drei Sätze voll, um dir dann zu sagen,
was denn wirklich Sache ist.
Sind Updates fertig? Updates sind die ganze Zeit
schon fertig.
Waren keine Updates mehr laufen.
Ja, Chat, dann würde ich sagen,
machen wir uns mal schlau.
Wie gesagt, ich habe nichts geplant für heute.
Wir machen uns jetzt mal schlau,
was bei dem MongoDB hackt.
Kann man bei deinem lokalen AI,
Das ist nicht lokale AI-Stells.
Das ist im Prinzip nur eine Software,
die das schön im Terminal einbinden lässt.
Also du kannst damit auch lokal...
Das ist hier OpenCode.
Das ist nicht...
Das ist nicht OpenCode.
WTF.
Das ist das Falsche.
Das da.
Die Software ist OpenCode.
Die Models sind kostenlos.
Aber nicht lokal.
Ich habe es auch mit lokalen Models probiert,
aber lokale models habe nichts gutes gefunden hier zum beispiel habe ich ein paar sachen mit
lm studio laufen das kannst du machen habe ich auch gemacht ich habe einen default prompt ich
kann ich kann euch meine ich kann euch meine config zeigen konnte ich hoffe ich habe da
keine api kies drin ist seck leute oder chat versprecht ihr mir weg zu gucken wenn api kies
drin sind.
Okay, gut.
Dann mach ich das jetzt auf.
Open
Code Config
Wim
Open Code JSON
Okay, da geht's los.
lasst mal kurz gucken habe ich api keys drin nein habe ich nicht nice guck mal
die habe ich alle ausgelagert andere falls keine api keys drin ja also was ich
habe ich habe die also die haben vier kostenlose models bei open code die man
benutzen kann gpt 5 nano glm 4.7 croc code und minimax m 2.1
hier habe ich hier sieht man ja nicht mal ein lokales angebunden zum ball
irgendwas gemacht zum beispiel hatte ich hier gpt oss 20b mal laufen das ist was
was noch ganz gut bei mir mit den ram und so gepasst hat das war aber alles
nicht nicht dass die default agents habe ich das abled ich habe ein modus für
frage für für für für fragen stellen der verwendet gelände 4.7 dann habe ich
ein prompt definiert das ist das was du meintest mit diesem kann man nicht die
fall überall dran hängen doch kann man zeige ich dir auch gleich ich habe ein
default prompt für alle für alle meine models dann habe ich auch ein paar tools
erlaubt tools sind die dinger die das model quasi außerhalb von seiner text
generation machen kann also das kann zum beispiel auf dateien zugreifen kann
per web request website abruf kann auf best zugreifen kann dokumente abruf
kann web suchen kann keine web suchen durchführen und hier unten drunter habe
ich sogar noch explizit geregelt was alles erlaubt ist in der bash und wie
gesagt meine models haben keinen right zugriff auf dateien also ich weib code
damit nicht alles verbot einzige wasser machen darf es mit cat dateien erstellen
nachdem er mich gefragt hat sonst davon nur ls und pwd machen so
So, dann habe ich das gleiche nochmal für Minimax ML 2.1.
Und nochmal für GPT-5 Nano.
GPT-5 Nano benutze ich nur, wenn es schnell gehen muss.
Und ehrlich gesagt so gut wie gar nicht.
Weil da kann man auch JetGPT direkt verwenden.
Oder den AI-Modus von Google oder irgendwas, wenn es kostenlos sein soll.
Guck mal, ich habe auch Thinking disabled, dass es schneller geht.
Die Antworten sind jetzt nicht so extrem geil von GPT-5 Nano.
So, dann habe ich noch ein paar kurze Kommandos.
Kommandos für README erstellen und Projekt erklären. Dann habe ich hier noch die zwei MCPs
angebunden, Context Team und Tavili, das hier für Websuche und das hier für aktuelle
Open Source Projekt Dokumentation. Und dann habe ich ein Default Prompt, WIM Default.
das habe ich mir genau das kriegt er quasi bei jedem chat am anfang mitge mitgepeilt das habe
ich von der offiziellen webseite für kontext 7 und kontext ihm ist wirklich nice also kammer zu
so ich kann das kann das kann man zeigen kann man zum beispiel pass auf jetzt
vorführeffekt es geht wahrscheinlich nicht da kann es wirklich sagen so
irgendwie man kann übrigens also deutsch und englisch ist immer so ein ding ja
ich habe den eindruck die ganzen models funktioniert ein tecken besser wenn man
sie in englisch benutzt aber gehen in deutsch auch vollkommen klar
gibt es neuere
APIs, die ich
in main.js
verwenden kann.
Mal gucken, ob der
Versionen...
Das ist natürlich eine bescheuerte Frage, aber da kommt
da schon was. Mal gucken, ob er selbst auf die Idee kommt,
Tavini zu suchen.
es denkt also dadurch dass es die free version ist bis auch manchmal ein
bisschen gedrosselt
naja guck guck mal jetzt will er web requests machen was eigentlich sehr
sinnig ist kann ich ihm sagen ja ja ok ok das web request stehen bei mir auf
ask da muss ich wirklich immer bestätigen dass er web requests machen
darf.
Okay, er denkt nicht, dass er Context 7
fragen muss. Oder aber
Tavili darf er eh nicht.
Er denkt nicht, dass er Context 7 fragen muss.
Oder vielleicht fragt er noch Context 7.
Ach, guck.
Ja, und man sieht, es ist ein bisschen langsamer
dadurch, dass es halt die komplette Free-Version ist.
Ah, das Model ist gut. Also für
kostenlos. Also ganz ehrlich, für
kostenlos kann man sich bei diesen drei Models wirklich
nicht beschweren. Ach, guck mal, jetzt
fragt er Context 7 nach.
Guck noch nach, ob es aktuelle Varianten gibt.
Ja, ja, ist ja gut.
Die Sachen darf er nicht machen.
Genau, jetzt erzählt er mir hier, was er gefunden hat.
Also, basier auf deiner Analyse des Codes
und der aktuellen Rust-Ökosystem-Updates.
Hier sind die wichtigsten Neuigkeiten.
Axum.
0.78.
du verwendest 0.8 x was also ich habe bereits ich wollte sagen was hat er denn
das wird was will er mit was will er mit allen mögliche verbesserung für deinen
code moderner ansatz für den websocket händler
Ah, oder?
Guck mal, es gibt, da sieht man, das hat richtig was gebracht hier mit Context 7 und den Websuchen,
weil das Model hätte normalerweise überhaupt keinen Plan, dass es Tokio 1.5 schon gibt.
Upgrade Opportunität
für dein Background Update.
Haha.
Es gibt eine neue Subversion.
Ja und sowas. Also da sieht man,
das ist schon nice, wenn man
aktuellen Kontext aus dem Internet bekommt.
Ja, das müssen wir uns nicht alles durchgucken.
Aber es ist schon nice.
Also ganz ehrlich, für das das alles kostenlos ist an der Geschichte.
Aber wo wir da dabei sind, ja.
Wenn etwas kostenlos ist, muss man sich fragen, ob man nicht selbst das Produkt ist.
Ist das schon echt nicht verkehrt.
Max, können wir mal wieder Plans für Zombies?
Nee, können wir nicht.
Kann ich auch sagen, warum.
Ich wollte eigentlich mal wieder spielen.
weil sie ja diese diese remastered geschichte angekündigt haben aber
nachdem ich gelesen habe dass das quasi komplette slob sein soll diese
remastered geschichte hat mich der bock darauf verlassen
da wollte ich nicht mehr gedacht nee dann nicht
guck also wenn sie mit der gab es ein remaster reep replanted das alte oder
das alte habe ich so viel gespielt
Ja, Schrott.
Gut, da gucken wir jetzt mal das Video
zu MongoDB.
Ne, ne, ne, nicht zu Honey.
Zu MongoDB.
Was da los gewesen ist.
Nein, wir gucken jetzt nicht hier.
MongoDB Situation is crazy.
Zwei Tage.
Sieht das aus, als wäre ich gerade aufgewacht.
Mongo Bleed.
schon mal schon mal guter name erinnert mich ein bisschen hart blieb von
ability that allows in an authenticated attacker to league sensitive server
memory ja okay das ist voll für nash da hast du gleich gelitten
da hast du gleich da hast du gleich gelitten
übers netzwerk ohne authentifizierung random sachen aus dem speicher muss so
lange noch auslesen dass wichtige sachen drin hast
... of the MongoDB server process.
Not a great place to be...
Sag mal.
... if you are in the world of maintaining...
Irgendwie ganz stimmt Sound und Lippenbewegung nicht.
Ist das in der AI... hat er sich AI generated?
... database infrastructure.
Also not a great place to be if you exist on the internet
because someone dropped this proof of concept publicly on Christmas.
If you're this guy, come on, brother.
You couldn't have waited until the next day over?
Whatever, it's fine.
Mongo bleed is an allusion to heart bleed,
die Widerständigkeit in OpenSSL von 10 Jahren her,
Gott, ich bin so alt, 2014,
was im Grunde die gleiche Sache mit OpenSSL passiert,
weil du durch eine Auslösung von Rehren
die Erinnerung aus OpenSSL leaken konntest.
So, was ist das?
Hartblitstelz.
Vor elf Jahren.
Da habe ich noch Videos gemacht.
Leute, ich war kurz davor, ein Video heute aufzunehmen.
So Neujahrsansprache-mäßig.
Boah, das ist so hell.
Das blendet mich.
Du hattest mal gesagt, du machst YouTube-Video, wenn Windows ihr EOL durchzieht.
Du meinst bei Windows 10 oder was?
Machen sie ja gar nicht, sie ziehen es ja nicht durch.
Kriegst ja mittlerweile Extended Support kostenlos.
Das ist ein Kompression-Algorithmus.
Um über Zlib zu sprechen, braucht man nicht authentiziert zu sein.
Man kann die Authentizierung-Transaktion über diese Zlib-Kompression machen.
Deshalb sind die Wunschwürdigkeiten, die durch Zlib ausgesprochen werden,
ausgesprochen zu Menschen vor der Authentizierung, unauthentizierten Attackern.
Ja.
So funktioniert das.
Du sendest dem Server eine kompresste Botschaft,
aber innerhalb der kompressten Botschaft kontrollierst du die Fälle, die sagen,
Oh, by the way, the uncompressed size of the data after it's been decompressed is this size, right?
You, the attacker, control that data.
Moment, Moment, Moment.
Sending a compressed message with inflated uncompressed size.
Also heißt...
Es ist schickende Nachricht mit komprimiertem Inhalt.
Aber ich sage gleichzeitig, dass es viel größer ist, wenn es entpackt wird, als es eigentlich ist.
Okay, MongoDB allocates a large buffer based on attacker-slam.
Okay, also kann ich sagen, hey, guck mal, hier ist eine komprimierte Nachricht. Unkomprimiert bin ich 512 MB groß.
und die Daten in den Buffer zu dekompressen.
Aber es bleibt noch mehr Raum, weil du gesagt hast, dass der dekompressierte Buffer
tatsächlich größer war, als es wirklich war.
Und dann wird MongoDB die ganze Transaktion als valid behandeln
und es wird die Antwort an dich schicken.
Die Grund, warum Leute das Mongobleed nennen, ist, dass das...
das heißt der Speicher wird nicht geserodet
sondern das ist einfach freier Speicher irgendwo im Prozess
Memory Space
der nicht geserodet wird und man
quasi dann nicht nur von
bis wohin die Nachricht reingeschrieben wurde, sondern alles zurückgeschickt
bekommt, wo dann halt auch theoretisch Sachen drin sein können, die
früher mal von einer anderen Stelle beschrieben wurden
und sensitive Sachen drin stehen, wenn ich das richtig verstehe
Ich frage, warum macht man denn, also bei sowas würde ich doch immer gucken, dass der Speicher wenigstens geserot wird nach dem Allocaten oder am besten schon gleich sagen, ich will Zero Allocated haben. Aber gut, das kostet natürlich Performance.
Ich kann mich an Heartfleet gar nicht...
Es ist gut, dass ich ein Video damals drüber gemacht habe,
Weil ich könnte mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern, was Hartplied 1, was da genau gewesen ist.
Boah, da bin ich jetzt aber verwundert, dass ausgerechnet er Windows benutzt.
Wenn wir in die, ähm, nicht Hallo-Welt gehen, wenn wir in Mongobleed gehen,
machen wir ein kleines Python 3 auf dem Mongobleed-Skript,
es wird den Payload an den Server senden,
und es wird die arbitrarischen Daten bis zu einem festen Anzahl
und das zu einem File schreiben.
Das ist der ganze Exploit. Es ist so einfach.
Und bevor wir weitergehen, schaut euch das an, Leute,
ich bin fast bei einem Millionen Abonnenten.
Wenn ihr das Subbutton schmackt, würde ich es wirklich lieben.
Es bedeutet dem Welt zu mir. Danke so viel.
Also die Magie des Exploits ist literally nur in dieser einen Python-Funktion hier.
sendprobe.
Ich glaube, wir haben es verstanden.
Das ist aber, ich bin immer wieder
erstaunt, dass es solche Sachen
gibt. Übrigens, by the way, das wäre nur so
eine Sache, die wäre dir mit Rust
nicht passiert.
Die wäre dir mit
jeder anderen x-beliebigen Managed-Sprache
aber auch nicht passiert.
Es sei denn, du machst da irgendwelche Unsafe-Sachen.
Da kannst du natürlich immer noch
umwurschteln.
... ein Messege an den Server zu senden, richtig?
Und es macht das mit Zlib-Kompression.
Und dann ist in der echten Messege, die kompresst werden wird,
du hast dieses OP-Kompress-Message, richtig?
Es ist eine Struktur, die MongoDB lesen kann,
um Informationen zu lesen,
was kompresst und dekompresst wird.
Und so hast du den originalen OP-Code,
das Messege, das an den Server gesendet wird.
Aber hier ist, wo all das Schlechte passiert, richtig?
Du hast die Buffer-Würfe.
Das ist die Größe, die der Server erzählt,
Ich glaube, wir haben es verstanden.
Was noch interessiert,
wie MongoDB darauf reagiert hat.
Moment!
Moment, Rainbow Six Siege Server?
Sind die von MongoDB Sachen betroffen?
Damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gedacht.
Damit hätte ich nicht gerechnet.
Rainbow Six Server.
Es gibt keine Begründung, dass es so ist, weil es die Breaking News ist.
Also VX Underground, der ist ein guter Hacker, Mauerwerber auf Twitter.
Im Grunde genommen hat er ein bisschen einen Rundum gemacht, was tatsächlich passiert ist mit Bezug auf Rainbow Six Siege.
Also es gab, glaube ich, mehrere Instanzen von Breachen von Rainbow Six Siege, die verschiedene Gruppen von Leuten betroffen haben.
Es gibt einen zweiten Gruppen von Leuten, der nicht zu dieser ersten Breache ist,
that did exploit the MongoDB
instance from Ubisoft using
Mongobleed, which allowed them to
pivot to an internal Git-Repo
and then they exfiltrated a large
portion of Ubisoft's internal source code,
which is probably...
Alter.
Ackermans am Start.
Das heißt, die haben Sachen rausbekommen
aus der MongoDB,
wo sie dann mit Zugriff
auf ein internes Git-Repo hatten.
Large portion of Ubisoft internal source code.
90er bis present.
Vielleicht hängen das wirklich zusammen, die Rainbow Six Siege Server und der MongoDB Hack.
Interessante Sache.
Ich hätte nicht gedacht,
dass das so große Auswirkungen wieder hat.
Aber klar, ich war MongoDB von vielen benutzt.
Kann schon sein.
Natürlich besonders bitter, wenn sowas an Weihnachten passiert.
Da ist aber keiner da.
Tja.
Hattest du Bereitschaft?
Nö.
Hatte ich nicht.
Ich hab den ganzen Monat Urlaub, da hab ich auch keine Bereitschaft
Gab diesen Monat da nicht viel Kohle
Oder gibt diesen Monat nicht viel Kohle
War der Java-Stelz nicht auch an Weihnachten?
Du meinst die Lock4J-Geschichte, ne?
Lock for Shell oder wie das hieß
Das könnte auch gewesen
Ich weiß es nicht
Irgendwas war in letzter Zeit auch mal
An Weihnachten
Achja okay
November 2021 war das
Dezember 2021
Ja was jetzt wie jetzt
Das könnte tatsächlich auch dann irgendwann
Um Weihnachten rum gewesen sein
Kennst du schon
Netzet written in Go?
Hat das die Welt gebraucht?
Zeig mal her
BB-Pod
Es ging um irgendwelche
Managed-Geschichten
Von MongoDB
Da musst du ja vom Internet aus drauf zugreifen können, weil wie willst du die sonst benutzen?
A prettier way to inspect network connections.
Aha.
Ein besseres
Netz-Stat.
Also dieses Tool hier,
der Ersatz für Netz-Stat,
hat deutschsprachigen Raum
eine echt schlechte Benahmung, oder?
Für den deutschsprachigen Raum.
Traust dich ja kaum, das auszusprechen,
dass nicht irgendeine AI auf Twitch angeht.
Und ich band.
Das ist so ein Ding, wo ich mir denke, das ist ein cooles Projekt.
Aber habe ich mir bei Netstat jemals schon mal irgendein User-Interface dazu gewünscht?
Bin ich mir unsicher, ehrlich gesagt.
Aber ich verwende solche Tools nicht.
Ich kann euch auch erklären, habe ich schon oft gesagt, warum ich solche Tools nicht verwende.
Das liegt daran, ich bin so oft per SSH Remote auf Servern unterwegs.
Deswegen habe ich übrigens mein Wim auch nicht mehr so krass customised wie früher.
Ich will das nicht verlernen, wie man die Sachen benutzt auf Systemen, die nicht bis zum Ende customised sind.
Deswegen benutze ich auch meistens FIND anstatt FD.
ganz normales krepp anstatt rg cd anstatt set oxide und was nicht alles
gibt oder ls weiterhin anstatt die ganzen riten in rast es der ersatz
tools dies ergibt ich will das einfach nicht verlernen wie man ein nicht
customizes system ordentlich bedient deswegen verwende ich die tools nicht
und man verlernt das schnell ich habe ich habe letztens ein video geguckt da
waren richtig gute tipps drin ich glaube dass hier ist das sogar genau hier 10 z
da waren da waren wirklich einige bekommen wir können wir sogar gucken
wenn ihr wollt ein paar gute tipps drin aber das ist auch wieder so auch wenn
ich mich daran gewöhne dann ist das ist das halt im normalen work
Ich würde es gerne im Terminal verwenden, mit meiner Wahlkarte.
Wir skippen mal ein bisschen, ne?
Ja.
The first item on this list is one that's an absolute game changer
when it comes to typing out long commands.
Especially if, like me, you sometimes make mistakes.
Picture this.
You're writing a long CLI command
and you realize you made a mistake about three lines back.
Auch das ist ein richtig guter Tipp, Leute.
Was jetzt kommt. Das ist richtig gut.
Three lines back.
In the past, I would normally fix this by navigating using the Z-Shell Keybindings, followed by fixing the actual mistake.
Ja, macht fast jeder so.
All of which feels extremely inefficient.
If all of this sounds familiar, then fortunately there is a much more efficient way, which is to make use of a widget called Edit Command Buffer.
This widget allows you to open up the Command Buffer inside of your computer's text editor.
Das ist doch mega nice, oder?
anstatt es jetzt da rum zu
editieren, hier mit Pfeiltasten
und sonst was, kannst, wenn es was
größeres ist, was du editieren musst
in deiner CLI, kannst du es einfach in Vim aufmachen.
Da drin editieren, speichern
und hast es wieder direkt auf der Command Line.
Das ist mega nice. Also
unter Bash wusste ich, dass es das gibt,
deswegen dachte ich auch immer, dass es das unter
Cish auch gibt, aber ich habe das nie eingerichtet.
Da bin ich ernsthaft
überlegen, ob ich das nicht einbauen sollte.
das Fehler mit meinen Wim-Keybindungen und die Änderungen werden an meinen Command Buffer
angewendet. In meinem Fall habe ich dieses Widget an die Keybindung von Ctrl-X und Ctrl-E
geblendet, das wurde mit den folgenden drei Linien konfiguriert, die in meinem .ZShellRC
gefunden sind. Persönlich finde ich es, den Edit Command Buffer zu nutzen, unglaublich
Das riecht gut.
Weiter.
Undo.
Nächster Tipp ist auch super.
Das habe ich auch öfters,
dass man dann mehr löscht, als man eigentlich löschen will.
Wusstet ihr, dass es das gibt?
Also das sind die zwei Dinger, wo ich mir auch jetzt wirklich ernsthaft überlege,
soll ich das nicht in meine Config einbauen?
Editieren in Vim und Undo.
Das klingt beides sehr praktisch.
Ja, Redo braucht man nicht.
Das wiederum, wir gucken uns mal an.
Aber ich sag gleich was zu.
dann spielst du effektiv russische Roulette.
das ist jetzt ja nicht dass das jeder zweite befehl ist dem man tippt also das
sieht cool in dem demo aus in der demo aus praktisch gesehen braucht man es
eigentlich nicht deswegen gibt man das jetzt das nächste finde ich auch nice zu
wissen dass es gibt so die vortrag um das liste ist ab dir moment chat gehen
Habt ihr Tipps, wie man das ganze Shell-Saxon einfach lernen kann? Ja, einfach täglich benutzen. Das ist wie bei vielem. Man kann sich noch so viele Tutorials angucken oder irgendwelche Guides oder sonst was. Nichts übertrifft selbst benutzen. Benutzt das einfach jeden Tag.
und wenn du sagst, ey, ich will doch
aber eigentlich gar kein Linux
quasi Haupt
ja, als Hauptbetriebssystem
einsetzen, dann hast du zwei Varianten
entweder
du benutzt WSL
oder du installierst eine Linux
VM und machst das wie ich
einfach auf dem zweiten Desktop eine Linux VM
und dann lernst du auch noch
drumherum neben Shell noch ordentlich
was über Linux. Das Beste
was du machen kannst, ist wirklich täglich den
Kram benutzen.
und versuchen damit halt auch Probleme zu lösen.
Es gibt viele, die das nicht kennen, mit Ausrufezeichen, Ausrufezeichen.
Ich würde sogar mal fast sagen, locker die Hälfte,
Das ist jetzt einfach mal so ein Gefühl, das ist ein Bauchgefühl.
50% der Leute, die regelmäßig was mit Deluxe machen, haben keine Ahnung davon,
dass du Ausrufezeichen, Ausrufezeichen für das letzte Kommando schreiben kannst.
Das ist aber auch nicht schlimm, weil man braucht es eigentlich nie.
So gut wie nie.
So weiter.
Aber das hier finde ich auch wirklich ganz nice.
Als Entwickler braucht man eine Shell selten.
Was? Ich brauch das laufend.
Und wir machen ja auch sehr viel
Proggers-Content im Stream.
Also wenn ich was entwickle...
Gerade Entwickler hat jeder so ein bisschen
seinen eigenen Workflow.
Weißt du, wie das bei mir aussieht, wenn ich was bastle?
Wir nehmen jetzt mal das hier.
Bei mir geht das immer los in der Shell-Session.
Immer.
Das ist ein Rust-Projekt.
Ich starte jetzt meine IDE.
Ich benutze mittlerweile Dev-Container, sodass ich von den ganzen Supply Chain Angriffen nicht so sehr betroffen bin.
Dauert dementsprechend einen Ticken länger, bis meine IDE offen ist.
Aber das erste Mal ist jetzt nicht so wild.
Müssen wir kurz warten.
Ich übe ein Rust-Projekt.
Das hat keinen größeren sittlichen, sittlicher Nährwert, hätte mein Opa da jetzt gesagt.
Das gibt es auch nicht auf GitHub. Das ist einfach nur zum Üben gewesen.
Guck hier da. Das macht nichts. Das stellt ein paar Metriken bereit und guckt, rechnet zusammen, wie viel...
Ah, Moment. Ich musste das ja noch richtige, das richtige Projekt starten.
rechne zusammen, wie groß alle Dateien
in einem Verzeichnis sind und sowas, nix
großartiges, einfach nur
ein bisschen Rust zu üben
so, und jetzt habe ich mal eine Frage
an den
ich sitze gerade im Chat nicht mehr
an den Gottverdammtlieberhund
ähm
wenn du als Entwickler das nicht
viel benutzt
ähm
machst du dann so Sachen wie Projekt ausführen und Projekt bilden und sowas,
machst du das hier über die IDE immer?
Ich weiß ja nicht, welche IDE du benutzt.
Also ich benutze die IDE wirklich nur zum Programmieren.
Alles andere mache ich über das Terminal.
Also guck mal hier, ich könnte jetzt natürlich hier drüber das Projekt bauen,
hier drüber das Projekt ausführen und sowas in der Richtung.
Mache ich nicht.
Ich benutze das rein zum Entwickeln.
Und wenn ich es dann wirklich ausführen will, mache ich hier Cargo Run zum Beispiel.
Oder noch besser habe ich hier eine Run-Datei oder mit Bacon oder so.
Das ist ein sehr nices Tool zum automatischen Reloaden.
Selbst mein Java-Zeug, was wir hier gebaut haben, wir haben ja letztens auch was in Spring Boot gemacht und mit Quarkus.
Selbst da habe ich alles über die Kommandozeile
gemacht, außer eben das Programmieren.
Ich finde das,
also das ist halt mein persönlicher Geschmack,
also je nachdem, soll jeder machen, wie das
am besten funktioniert. Ich finde es immer
hakelig, diesen ganzen Kram über die IDE
zu machen, wenn man gerade hier
gute Command-Line-Tools hat,
wie bei Quarkus oder hier bei
Rust oder bei Go auch.
Und bei mir ist es
halt so,
wenn man das hier ausführen zum Beispiel, so, jetzt lassen wir das Projekt mal laufen,
jetzt wenn ich jetzt hier was drin ändere, hier zum Beispiel, ich will das hier jetzt ändern,
dann reloadet er das automatisch für mich, die Web-Anwendung, guck hier, sieht ihr auch, ist gerade abgekackt,
zack, jetzt reloadet er und es läuft wieder und ich habe es gerne in der Shell,
weil ich so Sachen wie Endpunkte, also Web-Endpoints teste mit Curl und anderen Command-Line-Tools.
Man kann das alles, ich weiß, es gibt mittlerweile Möglichkeiten in der IDE,
dass man solche Request-Files macht, wo man dann in der IDE irgendwelche Requests ausführen kann.
ganz ehrlich, warum so kompliziert, die Shell ist das Beste dafür, da kann man Sachen curlen, man kann Websocket-Verbindungen mal schnell ausprobieren, wunderbar, man kann hier irgendwie auf der Kiste noch selbst was ausprobieren, man kann aber jetzt auch keine Git-Comments ordentlich machen, ganz ehrlich, ich persönlich hasse alle Git-Plugins von, angefangen von Visual Studio, Visual Studio Code, IntelliJ, beziehungsweise die ganzen Chat-Presents,
ich kann diese ganzen Git-Plugins,
ich kann die nicht ab,
auch für Wim nicht, ich kann die nicht ab.
Der einzige Weg, für mich
ordentlich Git zu benutzen, ist
Terminal. Das ist das einzige,
wie ich das benutzen kann.
Ja genau, eine der Sachen,
wofür ich es mir gefallen lasse, dass man
ein grafisches Frontend nimmt,
ist für einen ordentlichen Graph
malen, aber sogar das
geht ja.
Kann Git-Repo.
Aber sogar,
das haben wir irgendwo, haben wir irgendwo ein Git-Repo
hier, J, J, Git-Repo.
Ja, man kann auch sagen, Git log minus minus
graph und dann malt er solche
Dinger hier. Das ist natürlich, ey, okay,
ich gebe zu, das ist wirklich nicht so geil
im Vergleich zu nem ordentlichen
GUI dafür.
Aber so für ein bisschen Übersicht
ist das komplett, komplett
fein, ja.
Ich weiß nicht, ob wir hier irgendwie
ne, ähm,
wir können uns jetzt mal angucken
wie der Linux-Körnel
wie da die Comet
wie gesagt, es ist Geschmackssache
du bist da dran gewöhnt
das mit IntelliJ zu machen, deswegen kommst du damit
klar, ich bin es halt nicht gewöhnt
und immer wenn ich mich mal ein bisschen versucht habe
dran zu gewöhnen, fand ich es eklig
aber
okay, jetzt klonen wir erstmal eine halbe Stunde
bis wir die Linux-Körnel geklont haben
aber gut ist halt so
jetzt eine halbe stunde linux körner ganz so lange dauert es wahrscheinlich ich will
mich mal gucken wie das damit aussieht
aber chat ihr habt recht für tipps für tipps ist es auch ist es auch ganz gut sich das im
gui anzuzeigen wobei ich ja persönlich bei tipps tatsächlich wim diff bzw den ganz normalen edit
mode wo man dann diese marke im file hat auch gar nicht so schlecht finde gut lag gl hf
Also wie gesagt, ich kann dir nur empfehlen, das einfach täglich zu benutzen.
Und halt auch wirklich versuchen, Probleme damit zu lösen.
Dann kommst du da schnell rein.
Ganz im Ernst.
Also an Terminal-Befehlen, was brauchst du da?
Da brauchst du vielleicht 20 Befehle und du kommst gut hin.
So für Daily Usage.
Mit der Zeit lernst du noch mehr, aber mit 20 Befehlen kommst du schon gut hin.
Und Linux klont immer noch.
Aber was auf jeden Fall praktisch ist, wenn du dich dann halbwegs sicher fühlst im Terminal,
ein bisschen Shell-Scripting.
Das bringt ja auch als Entwickler viel.
Zum Beispiel für GitHub-Actions oder irgendwelche CI-Geschichten.
Oder sei es nur, wenn du wirklich dann über Kommandozeile benutzt hast,
dass du irgendwie einen Bildpunkt-SH hast, der Sachen für dich automatisiert und sowas.
Also ein bisschen Shell-Scripting ist das Beste.
Du musst jetzt kein Bash-Profi sein, wie Dings hier.
Ich hab so auch einen YouTube-Channel.
Warte mal, YouTube.
Bash.
Progress.
War.
Da hab ich letztens...
Ja.
Du musst ja nicht gleich der Experte sein wie er hier, wenn es um Bash-Skripting geht.
Da wird immer abgedreht, dass das Zeug fabriziert.
Guckt euch diesen Krempel hier teilweise mal an.
Man muss es ja nicht übertreiben mit Bash-Skripts, ja?
Aber so ein bisschen Bash-Skripting ist nicht verkehrt.
Was ist das? Das ist ein Projekt, wo ich selbst Rust mitlerne.
Das macht nichts Sinnvolles.
Das macht nur so ein paar kleine Übungssachen.
Wie groß sind alle Dateien in einem Verzeichnis zusammen?
Und solche Geschichten.
Einfach so ein bisschen Rust zu üben war das.
und dann stellt es das ganze per http zur verfügung als prometheus metrik und
sowas also das macht nichts großartig tolles worauf die welt gewartet hat
ich sehe öfters in vielen stellen anzeigen dass man linux kenntnisse braucht das wird
was wird denn da genau erwartet kannst du das kommt auf die stelle an würde ich mal
ganz spontan so sagen ja kommt auf die stelle an linux kenntnisse kann ja alles sein bei der
ich finde übrigens auch nicht schlimm wenn man da was wenn man da im vorstellungsgespräch ist
und das so fragt was was genau sie sich denn darunter vorstellen wenn sein interessiert
ja aber gesprächsstoff also wir haben mal eine hat sich mit langjähriger linux erfahrung beworben
haben wir rausgekriegt also dann vorstellungsgespräch herausgekriegt dass das im prinzip nichts anderes
war wie ubuntu mal vor fünf jahren in vor allem installiert langjährige erfahrung
also spontan würde ich sagen linux erfahrung was damit gemeint du kannst dich sicher auf
einer kommandozeile bewegen wobei das halt auch so ein ding ist es kommt immer auf den beruf an
ja also wenn du dich jetzt als linux admin bewirbst oder sowas gibt es ja nicht mehr
heutzutage sind das ja alles der fox engineers oder site reliability engineers oder sowas
oder wenn du dich jetzt ein entwickler beispielsweise bewirbst und da steht
linux kenntnisse da würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt erwarten dass du der krasse
kommandozeilen hacker mein bist aber ich würde zumindest erwarten okay kann sich auf dem linux
system so ein bisschen bewegen ja kannst meinen verzeichnis gehen und den log
datei angucken und sowas in der richtung würde ich erwarten wohingegen wenn sich
jetzt eine als linux admin bewirbt da würde ich schon mehr erwarten als dass
er sich sicher auf der kommandozeile bewegen kann und da ein paar sachen
ausführen ja da will ich dann auch erwarten dass der weiß okay wie
funktioniert log wie funktioniert system die so ein bisschen okay das weiß keiner
wie genau das zum die funktioniert aber wie start und stoppe ich sachen wie
wie erstelle ich ein Unit-File, wie kann ich Kernel-Log-Messages lesen gescheit,
Bash-Scripting und sonstige Geschichten.
Also es kommt ein bisschen auf den Job an.
Linux lernen ist die beste Investition überhaupt für die Zukunft, finde ich, in der IT.
Wenn man einen IT-Job hat.
Linux ist schon überall und Linux wird auch noch viel mehr sein in Zukunft, meiner Meinung nach.
außer auf desktops im business enterprise umfeld job listing review das one sec ja was ist
Okay
Kam gerade jemand rein
Ich weiß, dass ich mute war
Oder war ich nicht gemutet?
Habt ihr alles gehört?
Nee, oder?
Nee
Egal, war ja auch nichts Schlimmes
Was wollte ich sagen?
Job-Listing-Review.
I don't know yet.
First I need to make YouTube-Videos again.
But we can do it on Twitch.
Do you mean the YouTube-Videos
or the Twitch-Streams?
Ich würde sagen, wir machen es nächstes Jahr.
Auf Twitch.
YouTube.
Ja.
Ich weiß es noch nicht.
Noch nicht.
Das ist im D-Plus Linux.
keratostar gestützt für den sub
das video noch weiter ja ja ja ja machen wir machen
ganz ganz verpeilt linux linux ist fertig ausgecheckt wie sie meine
Schell lagged da drinnen.
Mal gucken, wie da der Craft aussieht.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh, keine gute Idee.
Das zu machen im Linux-Report.
Oh.
Ach, doch geht's.
Ja, so sieht das bei Linux aus.
Eine Güte, ey.
Die haben aber auch ordentliche
Comet-Messages, ne?
Also ich finde, mit dem Graf kann man durchaus was anfangen.
Ja, ein Gui ist schöner.
Das ist auf jeden Fall Kirby-Musik.
Aber ich finde, der Graf geht.
Aber ein Gui ist schon schöner.
So und jetzt muss ich das Ding mal ganz schnell wieder löschen.
Mal gucken wie groß das Linux Repo ist, wenn es ausgecheckt ist.
7,8 Gig.
Das geht doch voll klar.
So jetzt müssen wir das Video aber wirklich noch fertig gucken.
In einer halben Stunde muss ich übrigens weg.
Genau, ja, das hier.
Das fand ich auch super interessant, dass es das gibt.
Ich habe keinen Anwendungszweck dafür, aber es gibt in Z-Shell so viel, von dem man nichts weiß.
Es finde ich halt überflüssig
als Fuck, aber ich finde es cool, dass das geht.
Man könnte damit
zum Beispiel Environment-Variablen setzen
für bestimmte Projekte und sowas, wobei das
ziemlich unübersichtlich wird mit der Zeit.
Jetzt habe ich einen einfachen Hook, der automatisch eine Nix-Developed-Shell aufladen wird,
wenn ich eine Projektdirektorie beinhalte, die eine Nix-Flake enthält,
und wenn ich nicht schon in einer Nix-Shell bin.
Während es andere Mittel gibt, um das zu erreichen,
ist es immer noch sehr schön, diese Funktionalität in ZShell zu haben,
besonders wenn du dich um deine Systeme interessierst.
In Erneuerung zu Nix-Shells,
die zweite Weise, wie ich den CHPWD-Hook benutze,
ist, wenn es um Python-Projekte geht, die einen virtuellen Umfeld haben,
Das ist nice, ja. Das finde ich, das ist ein guter Anwendungszweck.
Aber ich finde es cool, dass es das gibt. Ich habe jetzt keinen Anwendungszweck für, aber ich bin immer wieder begeistert, was so alles in Z-Shell drin ist. Sponsor. Moment, skippen wir mal.
Guck, dazu muss ich sagen,
Chat, Chat, da sind wir wieder beim Thema.
Er verwendet irgendwelche Nicht-Standard-Tools.
Wenn ich mich jetzt dran gewöhne,
bett anstatt scat zu verwenden, dann tippe ich das auch auf irgendwelchen Servern und
dann wundere mich, warum es nicht funktioniert. Nicht nur, dass ich super noob-kack-mäßig
dumm aussehe, wenn jemand sieht, dass ich bett anstatt scat tippe und es aufs Server
nicht funktioniert, es ist auch nervig. Also deswegen benutze ich diese Sachen nicht.
Schaust du privat YouTube-Videos in normaler Geschwindigkeit?
Ja, aber ich mache meistens den hier.
Warte mal, ich mache meistens den hier.
Und dann, wenn ich da bin, wo es mich interessiert,
lasse ich in normaler Geschwindigkeit weiterlaufen.
Man kann nämlich den, also für alle, die das noch nicht wissen,
Man kann die Maustaste gedrückt halten in einem YouTube-Video und dann spult er in zweifacher Geschwindigkeit.
Ohne, dass man hier unten das so doof umstellen muss.
Finde ich cool, dass es funktioniert.
Ganz im Ernst, ich schreibe einfach WIM davor und dann geht das auch in WIM auf.
Da brauche ich keinen automatischen Händler für Dateien.
Name and it will open it up for me in BAT, allowing me to read it at my leisure.
Both of these behaviors have been achieved
using something called suffix aliases, which are very similar to typical aliases
in ZShell, but they run based on a commands suffix, i.e. .json or .nd.
To show how these work, let's go ahead and create a suffix
alias in .go files so that they'll be opened up using NeoVim.
To do so, you first use the alias...
I learned a lot in this video too.
Ich habe für die meisten der Dinge keine Anwendungen,
aber einige sind wirklich cool.
Und die ersten beiden,
die undo und die Buffer-Kommand,
werde ich in meine Konfiguration einbauen.
Das bedeutet, dass es für alle Befehle, die in .go enden, funktioniert.
Letztlich müssen wir die Befehle, die wir nutzen wollen,
in den Editor Environment Variable einstellen,
der in meinem Fall nahe ist.
Jetzt, wenn wir ein File spezifizieren, das in .go endet,
wird es...
Das ist cool, dass es das gibt, aber...
Ach, ich weiß nicht. Das braucht man nicht.
as a simple alias that you can then just drop in into a larger command.
Es ist schon geil, was da alles möglich ist und eingebaut ist, ne?
You know what I mean? I often like to check my disk usage.
Jetzt mal ganz ehrlich davon, Leute.
Ihr habt doch bestimmt auch von der Hälfte dieser Sachen hier noch nichts gehört, oder?
Using the du-Command at my system root.
However, whenever I do, I often get back a bunch of errors for files that can't be checked,
which ends up polluting my disk usage stats.
These can be resolved by forwarding the errors to //dev//null.
Jetzt kommt auch was sehr Praktisches, was ich richtig cool finde.
Ja, guck, da spart man sich dieses blöde def0-Geschreibe.
Finde ich richtig cool.
Wieder aber mein Punkt, ich verwende es nicht, weil ich dann verlerne, wie ich es richtig benutzen muss.
Aber es ist cool, dass es geht.
Also wenn jemand wirklich nur auf seiner Kiste arbeitet und nicht permanent jeden Tag auf 50 verschiedenen Systemen ist,
dann kein Ding, dann optimiert das Zeug bis zum Gehtnichtmehr.
Aber für mich ist es halt nix.
a good pattern to stick to.
Okay, so this next hack is one
that's incredibly useful if you happen to use
the terminal to manage files, specifically
when it comes to batch moving
or batch renaming,
for which ZShell provides
a command that is incredibly powerful.
This is the ZMV command,
which is an advanced move command
found in ZShell, allowing you to move
files around, making use of pattern matching.
By default, the ZMV command
isn't available in ZShell.
However, you can enable it by using the following autoload command.
Once enabled, we can then use it to perform file management that anyone who lives inside
of a GUI is going to be envious about.
For example, let's say I want to rename a bunch of log files so that they have the extension
of .txt instead of .log.
Rather than writing a script to do this, I can simply type in the file name.
Wahrscheinlich würde ich einfach schnell eine Schleife tippen.
Da wäre ich wahrscheinlich schneller wie irgendwas anderes.
Ich würde dann irgendwie sowas hier machen, keine Ahnung.
For i in Sternchen Punkt was auch immer.
Wo gehen wir denn mal hin hier?
Rust.
Source hier.
For i in Sternchen Punkt rs.
Du Echo Dollar i dann.
Bam.
So, und dann würde ich sagen hier mv das nach da, also irgendwie so.
Da wäre ich wahrscheinlich schneller dabei.
Wobei das in der Tat gar nicht so einfach ist mit dem Rename.
Es ist schon nice, aber wie gesagt, gewöhne ich mich dann auch zu sehr dran.
Das ist doch nicht mal gültiger Regex.
Das ist so Spezialsyntax wieder.
Das wusste ich, dass es das gibt.
Das verwende ich aber auch nicht, weil ich die Syntax so hakelig finde mit dem Tilde-Ding.
Zeigt er auch gleich.
Also das meine ich nicht.
Das ist aufrufen.
für YouTube. This is pointing to the directory where all of my YouTube projects are stored.
Now if I want to quickly reference that directory...
So wirst du dann auf deine Directory-Aliases zugreifen. Ich wusste, dass es das gibt,
aber da bin ich nie auf die Idee gekommen, das zu verwenden. Generell muss man halt sagen,
diese ganzen Hacks in der Shell, die sparen alle nur so halbe Sekunde versus ganz normale
eine History Search.
Guck mal, bevor ich jetzt
getippt habe,
keine Ahnung hier,
CD-Dings-YouTube,
gehen wir mal davon aus, das wäre mein Download-Verzeichnis
oder sowas, ja?
Da habe ich entweder gemacht CD-Downloads
direkt von ihr oder
ich habe die History gesucht und Downloads gemacht.
Da bin ich schneller, als
CD-YouTube oder
CD-DL zu tippen.
In any of my commands, I can do so by using the Tilt-Sign, followed by the...
Shell History Search ist einfach das Beste.
...to open it up in my operating systems file manager.
Personally, I find named directories are really useful when it comes to any folders that I often work with...
Ich finde das nicht so nützlich.
...however, when it comes to actually navigating the files, I'll leave the description down below.
Okay, so now we're on to the final two, which is more about customizing certain actions when it comes to the command line buffer.
Das wird auch ein bisschen schwierig.
ich richtig cool. Das ist ein Clear, nur dass das Kommando nicht löschen muss. Das finde ich sehr
praktisch. Das werde ich wahrscheinlich auch in meine Config einbauen, weil das ist so ein Ding,
so ey, ob du das jetzt auf dem Server zur Verfügung hast oder nicht, juckt nicht. Kann
man ruhig lernen. Das finde ich praktisch, weil es kommt total oft vor, dass man schon was getippt
hat und sich denkt, ah jetzt würde ich gerne einen Clear vorher machen. Wie ich das jetzt
jetzt immer mache ist folgendes also mal angenommen ich tippe jetzt hier gerade was ja grepp omega
null und ich sage ach mist ich wollte doch eigentlich hier davor jetzt ein clear machen
was ich dann immer mache ist ich kommentiere das aus, cleare und dann führe ich es wieder aus so ist schon cooler
Warum nicht Ctrl-K? Weil ich mir das immer nicht merken kann, was das Shortcut ist für
für
Clearn. Oder ist es nicht L? L ist es.
L ist es. Genau.
Steuerung L.
Ach, das geht auch?
Lull!
Da muss man das überhaupt nicht
binden.
Das ist ja
komplett unsinnig.
Das ist standardmäßig schon
Control L.
Siehst du mal. Gut.
Gut, dass wir drüber geredet haben.
Übrigens, eines der geilsten Sachen ist eh das hier.
Als Extensions.
Guck dir mal.
Wenn ich jetzt hier anfange zu tippen,
LS, dann zeigt er mir an,
das letzte LS-Kommando,
also das letzte Kommando, was damit gestartet hat,
wie ich das weiter,
ähm, damals,
wie es weiter geschrieben wurde, ja.
Und jetzt kann ich einfach bei mir hier Ende-Taste drücken
und dann autocomplietet das automatisch.
Das ist quasi Copilot,
ohne Copilot zu sein.
Das ist bei Phish, ja, ich weiß, es kommt sogar
ursprünglich von Phish. Das finde ich sehr praktisch.
Also zwei
ZSH-Plugins, die ich sehr nice
finde. Das erste ist das hier,
also hier mit Find, bla bla bla,
Find, und jetzt
Autocomplete, das letzte.
Ist das History-Based?
Ja, das guckt, was das letzte
Kommando ist aus der History, was damit
angefangen hat.
Und das nächste ist, dass ich
guck hier, zack,
dass ich Syntax Highlighting habe für Skripts in der Shell.
Also dass mir das meine Sachen hier Syntax Highlighted.
Und dass ich hier beispielsweise auch Schleifen schreiben kann
und sehe dann, wo es anfängt und aufhört.
Das sind zwei Plugins.
Das ist einmal...
Das ist einmal hier ZSH Syntax Highlighting
und einmal ZSH Autos
Autosuggestions
die gibt's im
Standard Repo drinne
also das ist jetzt nix was man irgendwie
sich ein G-Tripo klonen muss und dann
Dinger da von Hand hin kopieren
die gibt's ganz normal hier
über den
äh
ja
ZSH
Completion
Oder ist es das?
Bin ich jetzt blöd? Wo ist es denn?
Erstmal mein Rust-Programm hier oben wieder.
Eindeutig ist über das System installiert.
Ach, nicht Completion, Suggestion.
Das da, genau.
Das ist richtig.
das ist default mäßig auch hier im repo wo ich mir nicht ganz sicher bin ob wie
es unter ubuntu und debian aussieht wir können mal kurz gucken
ubuntu 11.10 jetzt vielleicht nicht unbedingt nehmen wir mal ein aktuelles
25.10
ob das bei ubuntu auch dabei ist
mal search suggestion ist auch dabei und syntax ist auch dabei ja dann easy und wie sieht's bei
debian tricksy aus ist wahrscheinlich aber auch dabei wenn es bei ubuntu dabei ist
schauen wir mal kurz
Absearch, Syntax, dabei. Suggestion, sug, sug, ist auch dabei. Ja, also das finde ich, diese zwei Dinger.
Schauen wir das hier noch gerade fertig.
Okay, so the last ZShell-Hack on this list is by no means the least.
In fact, I might even consider it my favorite.
This hack allows you to basically configure Hotkeys for inserting into your command buffer,
which, yes, is as powerful as it sounds.
For example, let's say I want to bind a Hotkey to insert a git commit command
with my cursor placed inside of the quotes.
Das ist richtig cool. Das ist auch richtig cool.
War mir auch nicht klar, dass es das gibt.
Das sind so Arten, nenne ich wirklich Makros.
Ja doch, doch so ein bisschen, so eine Art Makros, nur in ZSH.
Das ist schon cool, oder?
Aber das werde ich nicht benutzen. Ich finde es zwar cool, aber das werde ich nicht benutzen, weil ich mir den Kram eh nicht merken kann.
Da definiere ich mir zehn Dinge, die super praktisch sind in meiner Shell-Config, aber das nächste Mal habe ich schon wieder vergessen.
Aber das ist ein echt gutes Video gewesen. Da waren viele Sachen dabei.
Und ganz ehrlich, die Hälfte davon, mindestens die Hälfte davon,
hab ich auch noch nie was von gehört.
Krieg ich eigentlich wieder für komische Videos empfohlen.
Ja, das ist so.
Aber man muss erst mal so den Einstieg finden.
Ich hab das schon öfters gehabt. Ich hab mir Sachen, coole Sachen konfiguriert und dann ist mir ein halbes Jahr später aufgefallen, Moment, du hast doch da mal was gemacht.
Das ist genauso, wie ich mir auch immer vornehme, ordentlich meine ganzen Unterlagen hier einzusortieren und mach's dann nicht. Und such dann immer eine halbe Ewigkeit, bis ich was gefunden hab.
wie neujahrsvorsätze
So, Chad, was gibt's noch?
Ich hab noch 11 Minuten Zeit,
da muss ich weg.
Irgendwelche wichtigen Themen.
Ich werde jetzt mal
rebooten.
Ne, werde ich nicht.
Sinnlos, ich muss nicht rebooten.
Ja, da hast du recht.
Das ist sinnvoll.
Manchmal stellt sich auch raus, dass Sachen, von denen man denkt,
die sind ganz cool,
eigentlich
so gut wie nie benutzt werden.
Und doch nicht so geil sind. Ich hatte auch mal eine ganze Weile
einige Git-Aliasse.
Und letztendlich habe ich von meinen
Git-Aliassen immer nur,
hat sich dann rausgestellt, immer nur
das hier verwendet.
Status.
Benutzt du FZF?
ganz selten mal das ist auch wieder der gleiche punkt wie ich will mich nicht
daran gewöhnen weil ich dann auf irgendwelchen remote system wo es nicht
drauf ist ja mein workflow nicht mehr passt wofür ich benutze beziehungsweise
benutzen würde ist beispielsweise wenn ich irgendwelche lokalen tools ab so was
sich hier drei sachen zur auswahl peinlich fzf und dann auswählen und so
was dafür ist das nice aber ich würde beispielsweise nicht meine bash oder
meine zsh history search dadurch ersetzen wie das manche leute machen
ich muss jetzt auf dem friedhof zur oma opa ans grab noch ein lichtchen stellen
neues
Ja genau, das ist genau mein Punkt.
Deswegen, deswegen...
...mach ich das nicht.
Aber das ist immer ein bisschen anwendungs-, also anwendungsfallabhängig.
Wenn man jetzt beispielsweise Entwickler ist,
und eigentlich nur auf seiner Kiste unterwegs ist, ab und zu mal vielleicht auf dem System,
ey, dann kann man da bis zum Umkippen jeden einzelnen Tastendruck optimieren und customizen,
weil man muss sich nie auf anderen Kisten großartig zurechtfinden, sondern auf seiner.
Und dann, jeden Tastendruck, den du sparen kannst, kannst du wegoptimieren und sparen.
Das ist alles gut, ja.
Aber wenn man halt einen Job hat, wo man den ganzen Tag über auch auf Remote-Systemen unterwegs ist,
per SSH, dann macht es keinen Sinn.
Warum soll sich mein Linux komplett anders bedienen, lokal als Remote auf dem Server?
Da hast du dich so dran gewöhnt und vertippst dich dann da nur noch.
Das Problem hatten die Leute früher schon, wenn sie mal bei mir an der Tastatur was tippen sollten.
Ich hatte damals einer der wenigen Leute bei uns als T-Mux.
Mittlerweile bin ich ja selbst kein großartiger T-Mux-Benutzer mehr.
Und da haben die Leute immer nicht gecheckt.
Max, wie scrollt man bei dir nochmal?
Moment, das geht ja nicht.
Steuerung B hochscrollen.
Ich bin weggekommen von T-Mux.
Und wisst ihr warum?
Weil ich ein Terminal habe, was Native Splits kann.
Alter.
Mon KS.
So.
also ich habe ein terminal so eingerichtet wie meine ungefähr wie meine thema shortcuts also
sprich ich kann hier zwischen zwischen unterschiedlichen tabs ich kann die splitten
vertikal horizontal ich kann die suchen und wieder klein machen also wenn die unten beispielsweise im
fullscreen läuft kann ich sagen okay ich will das nicht im fullscreen minimiert modus fullscreen
machen so also alles was ich mit thema gemacht habe kann ich auch machen
der einzige vorteil den man mit thema hat ist wenn man das auf remote server
ausführt weil da kommt nämlich dazu wenn du jetzt deine verbindung verliert dahin
oder was über nacht laufen lassen willst nicht das notebook an lassen möchtest du
sowas da kannst du oder dich am anderen morgen einloggen willst gucken willst
wie es aussieht da kannst du die session mit team max einfach auf lassen nämlich
dich die test das ist aber was das brauche ich ja lokal auf meiner linux
kiste nicht und seitdem ich den terminal hat was diese ganzen window manager
mäßigen dinge unterstützt brauche ich bei mir lokal kein thema mehr auf
servern habe ich immer thema am start allein schon weil man sonst durchdreht
denn bei uns ist es so ich versuche euch das mal kurz zu kann euch das nicht
zeigen.
So, wir gehen jetzt hier per SSH
auf einen Server. Ja, das ist ein Server,
der steht jetzt am Nordpol.
Oder in China.
Stellt euch das einfach mal vor. Das ist ein lokaler
Container, aber ist wurscht. So, ich bin jetzt hier
auf dem Server in China am Start.
Und bei uns
auf der Arbeit ist das so,
jedes Mal, wenn ich mich per SSH verbinde,
geht das nicht etwa so schnell.
Nein, da muss ich zwei Faktor-Authentifizierungen
machen. Da muss ich eintippen.
Ich muss eigentlich noch mehr machen.
Wenn ich mich per SSH
auf der Arbeit verbinde, muss ich
erstmal mein
Active Directory Passwort wissen.
Dann muss ich
in einem Key Generator
Keys generieren
zum Einloggen. Und dann
muss ich noch ein Reason mit gültiger
Ticketnummer eingeben.
So. Und jetzt überlegt
ihr euch mal. Ihr wollt
zwei SSH Verbindungen
aufmachen auf die gleiche Kiste.
Dann wirst du ja verrückt
mit der Zeit.
Deswegen einfach Temux starten auf der Kiste
und alles über eine SSH-Verbindung machen.
Temux habe ich auf der Arbeit
immer am Start, aber halt auch nur Remote.
Ja, aber du kannst dich ja ohne
Temux detachen oder was?
Check ich nicht. Hä? Ne, du kannst dich ohne Temux nicht detachen.
Wie soll das funktionieren?
Okay, ich zeig dir, wie ich das meine
Ich zeig dir, wie ich das meine
So, ich bin jetzt hier remote auf meiner Kiste drauf
Hier, Temux starten
Gehen wir mal hier rein
Bla
Äh
So, ich hab jetzt hier mein Projekt laufen
Ich will, ich will, dass das
Dass das jetzt über Nacht läuft
So, und jetzt, ups
Ups
meine Internetverbindung ist abgebrochen,
meine SSH-Verbindung, meine Session ist weg.
Jetzt wäre normalerweise, würde das jetzt abkacken auf dem Server.
Weil das an meiner Shell hängt, die Shell hängt an meiner SSH-Session
und die SSH-Session hängt halt hier an meinem Terminal
beziehungsweise an meiner Internetverbindung.
Oder ich habe das Notebook ausgeschaltet oder sonst was.
Sobald das Time aus ist, wäre das jetzt Remote auf dem Server weg.
jetzt verbinde ich mich wieder per ssh und sage tmux attach und bin wieder da und es lief einfach
weiter guck hier bin ich wieder ich kann mich auch manuell detachen und scheuung bd detached
wieder einloggen tmux a bin an gleicher stelle wieder da das meine ich und das ist halt einfach
beste an thema hat man verstanden oder also dafür ist das ungeschlagen
früher die leute screen verwendet und so ekliges zeug ganz ehrlich verwendet
teambox wofür wofür thema auch richtig gut ist wenn ihr jetzt mehrere user
habt die auf einem server eingeloggt also nicht user admin user eingeloggt
sind auf einem server man kann sich mit dem box auch eine session share also guck mal hier hier
oben user hier und user dem box und ihr seht session geschehen dass hier unten könnte beispielsweise
auch das hier ist admin 1 ist hier ohne sat man zwei man kann man kann damit seine session
scheren ich sehe jetzt was der tippt und er sieht was ich tippe
ob es jetzt habe ich geschlossen aus versehen
wenn steuerung die anstatt steuerung bdr das ist natürlich ja gut ist aber nicht
schlimm da machst du thema ist halt wieder auf beste also wer noch kein
thema verwendet und oft remote auf servern unterwegs ist sollte damit jetzt starten
es gibt kaum was was das leben so sehr erleichtert remote als teams ist noch in
der finanzbranche ja bin ich war ich bei einer bank jetzt bin ich bei der versicherung
gleicher punkt bei mir ich kaste meines ist nicht weil ich auf server benutze und ich
keinen bock hat überall eine thema config hinzuschieben wo ich mich einloggen
ok leute das muss ich weg bisschen früher als gedacht ich wollte eigentlich
noch bis 17 uhr da bleiben aber da gehe ich hier mal eine runde
ich weiß nicht ob ich heute abend am start bin müssen wir mal schauen
wir sehen uns dann spätestens wahrscheinlich morgen. Wir haben noch die
ganze Woche übrigens frei, also Freitag auch.
Goodbye, macht's gut, see you!